la Cumbre de la reconexión y la
renovación así la han calificado en el
Palacio del Eliseo este encuentro entre
los líderes del Reino Unido y Francia
que tiene lugar cinco años después de la
última Cumbre normalmente estos
encuentros se realizan cada dos años o
cada año sin embargo las polémicas
declaraciones de Boris Johnson en el
brexit el covid los alejaron a los
mandatarios de ambos países de hecho la
polémica sobre las licencias de pesca
que el Reino Unido tenía que entregar a
Francia y que tardó mucho tiempo
justamente en entregar y luego la
polémica sobre aucus es Alianza
defensiva entre Australia Estados Unidos
y el Reino Unido en el Indo Pacífico que
dejó fuera a Francia que además se vio
perjudicada porque no pudo vender los
submarinos Australia sin embargo Richie
sunak viene con una actitud
completamente diferente desde un primer
momento ella dijo que Francia es un país
Aliado un socio un amigo dicen además
que es joven Y tecnócrata como el
presidente Manuel macron que fue a él al
primer mandatario que contactó tras ser
electo de octubre del año pasado y que
juntos intercambian mensajes sobre
fútbol hay varios temas en carpeta en
esta Cumbre que durará todo este día
viernes el primero de ellos es la guerra
en Ucrania ambas potencias nucleares de
Europa deben justamente recuperar la
confianza en temas defensivos y pondrán
de acuerdo en la capacidad militar que
tienen a los europeos pero también En
formar y enviar materiales a Ucrania de
hecho varios tanques del Reino Unido
están siendo enviados a ese país también
la posibilidad de formar a los militares
ucranianos también otro tema importante
es la migración el brexit y los
conservadores hablaban justamente de que
este serviría para recuperar el control
de sus fronteras pero no ha sido el caso
el año pasado llegaron más de 46.000
migrantes sin documentación al Reino
Unido Diez mil más que en el año 2021
algo está pasando en los acuerdos entre
Francia y el Reino Unido es un tema
importante
acaba de presentar una ley muy
restrictiva justamente que impide casi
el derecho de asilo a las personas que
llegan sin documentación a su país será
otro tema clave Porque además el próximo
año hay elecciones en el Reino Unido y
es un tema fuerte de los conservadores y
finalmente otro tema es la energía
nuclear A diferencia de Alemania el
Reino Unido coincide con Francia en que
debe ser esta energía la que permita la
transición ecológica y la
descarbonización de la economía